[Music]
it's been one of the most dramatic
implosions in retail in December of 2013
the share price for Bed Bath and Beyond
was about eighty dollars
by the summer of 2022 that number had
collapsed over 90 percent to about five
dollars the decline of Bed Bath and
Beyond share price as well as its
profitability has raised serious
questions about its continued existence
Bed Bath and Beyond really needs to
figure out a way to exist in a world
where consumers can order pretty much
anything they want for their home from
Amazon and have it within days so what
happened to this once prosperous company
for it to have such a dramatic fall in
Share value and what might be next for
the once pioneering retail Giant
for decades now Bed Bath and Beyond has
been a fixture across North America with
locations in every state the District of
Columbia Puerto Rico and Canada what was
unique to Bed Bath and Beyond is the
individual store managers had a lot of
autonomy to run their store to suit
their particular customers needs so
stores they would order merchandise
based on their local markets it wasn't
sort of this uniformity that you see in
a lot of big chains and they could
really customize their store to meet
their local customer needs the company
helped Pioneer The Big Box Superstore
format the competed with department
stores and mass Merchants it really
became known as the place to go if you
needed anything for your home Shoppers
could walk in and just find anything
from sort of Oddball kitchen gadgets to
bedding to bath towels to cookware to
cuisinarts and they had a pilot High Let
It Fly philosophy where goods were
literally piled sometimes all the way to
the ceiling and you know people just
didn't really walk out empty-handed and
on top of it they had this 20 off coupon
so you could get name brand Goods at a
very good price but after Decades of
strong sales signs of weakness began to
emerge in the late 2010s the problems
really started just recently around 2018
2019 after many many years of rising
sales their sales fell their profits
evaporated and it's a culmination of a
lot of the changes we've seen in
retailing with the ship to online
shopping competition from new players
like Amazon and Bed Bath and Beyond had
really fallen behind the times they had
not invested in their technology their
online presence was slow and clunky they
just were not keeping Pace with all the
changes in 2019 the company brought in a
new CEO Mark Triton to turn things
around Mark Triton was a former Target
executive he ran there he was there
Chief Merchant at Target for several
years and he came in with a strategy to
really overhaul
um the whole company everything from
decluttering the stores adding more
private label brands uh remodeling
stores boosting the online presence you
know investing in Systems and Technology
he had a very wide-ranging plan to try
to bring the company more into the
modern retailing era in 2021 Bed Bath
and Beyond reopened its flagship store
in Manhattan's trendy Chelsea
neighborhood he added a lot of new
private label Brands very quickly Brands
like Nest wealth or betting and bath and
he added you know a lot for the kitchen
area and in so doing he took out some of
the national brands that Shoppers really
loved but Triton was not successful not
only did income continue to decline but
the company has also seen its debt pile
up to unsustainable levels well
unfortunately Mr Triton was trying to
make all these changes in a time of
tremendous upheaval for retailing the
pandemic ushered in a host of supply
chain challenges first there were
product shortages there have been
shipping delays bottleneck said overseas
factories it's made it very hard for
retailers to get goods and then once the
goods arrived consumer demand shifted
and now the goods are finally hitting
stores consumers are spending on other
things like travel and entertainment and
buying less of the Home Goods items that
Bed Bath and Beyond sells the global
pandemic initially wreaks havoc on the
retail sector in 2020 lockdown Shoppers
steer clear of brick and mortar stores
which led to a spike in e-commerce but
as the lockdowns eased consumer Behavior
normalized somewhat as Shoppers returned
to stores whereas retailers like Walmart
and Target quickly adapted to capitalize
on the returning foot traffic Triton's
strategy of adopting private label
Brands was hampered by supply chain
bottlenecks what's more Triton's
remodeling of the stores confused
returning Shoppers they've been
remodeling stores to give them wider
aisles they've taken out a lot of the
Clutter the stores do look cleaner but
they're sort of a nested size and
they've lost that specialness and loyal
Shoppers have really noticed the
difference and they're not so happy
about it in July of this year Triton was
ousted currently a board member serving
as interim CEO while the company
searches for a permanent replacement
Ryan Cohen the billionaire founder of
chewy.com took a stake in Bed Bath and
Beyond earlier this year and pushed for
some changes including separating its
Bye Bye Baby chain and the board is
evaluating options for the Bye Bye Baby
business but they have not reached a
decision yet things have gotten so bad
that some analysts have suggested that
bankruptcy is a possibility given the
rate at which the company is burning
through its cash reserves they're seeing
sales decline you know quarter after
quarter so they really need to to pull
consumers back into their stores they
need to figure out a way to create a
proposition that you know to make
Shoppers want to come and spend money
there in an email to the Wall Street
Journal a Bed Bath and Beyond
representative wrote we have a one
billion dollar asset-based revolving
credit facility additionally we have
already taken actions on many fronts
including a reduction of at least 100
million dollars of capex against the
company's original plan additional
measures are being pursued and we are
working with an external advisor brg to
focus on cash inventory and balance
sheet optimization the company will
provide a further update at the end of
next month
foreign